يحاول المواطنون هنا العوده الى منازلهم
وتفقدها لكن قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم
تبقي منازل في هذه المنطقه حتى ان ابراج
المقوس والبالغ عددها 23 برجا تحوي على
عددا من المباني الحكوميه دمرت تدميرا
كاملا ولم تبقي الا برجا واحدا محروقا كما
يظهر بهذا الفيديو واجزاء من برج اخر ايضا
احرقته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ونسفت
بقيه الابراج نسفا
كاملا يدرك المواطنون هنا تماما ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تدفعهم بهذا التدمير
الى الهجره الا انهم يصرون على البقاء في
هذه المنطقه وعدم تركها او النزوح منها
رغم ما حدث بها من دمار ورغم ملاحقتهم من
قبل جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من منطقه الى
منطقه انا ثابت حتى الموت هنا ثابت ثابت
ثابت اه صامدون حتى الموت لن نرحل وان شاء
الله باذن الله تعالى الرحيل لهم باذن
الله تعالى اج ام عاجلا هذه عياده الانرو
في منطقه المقوسي وهي تخدم عشرات الالاف
من اللاجئين الذين يقطنون في منطقه الشيخ
رضوان ومحيطها دمرتها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كما تشاهدون وعاثت بها فسادا
لم تعود هذه العياده تصلح مجددا للعمل فقط
ابقت على الم ودمرت جميع المرافق بداخلها
وجميع المعدات دمار شامل لكل ممتلكات
المواطنين مواطنين ابريا ليس لهم علاقه في
لا في حماس ولا في مقاومه بس مجرد انتقام
من الشعب الفلسطيني اللي ل تهجيره الهدف
تهجير الشعب الفلسطيني ولكن نحن باقون على
هذه الارض لن نغادرها باي شكل من الاشكال
ارضنا وبقو عليها في كل منطقه تنتهي قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من نسفها او تدميرها
يخط جنود الاحتلال بعض العبارات وكانها
عبارات النصر على حساب انقاذ هذه المباني
المدنيه والتي هي في الاساس تخدم فقط
الشرائح المدنيه في قطاع غزه وهذه كانت
هنا تجمعا للوزارات المدنيه عدا عن ان هذه
كما تشاهدون عياده العوده التي تخدم عشرات
الاف المواطنين بالامراض التخصصيه باسعار
رمزيه دمرتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ايضا بالاضافه الى كما قلنا تدمير عياده
الانروا
بالكامل